6 27 on your friday morning we're
ramping up for another few days of
finding another way to get around part
of the 95 in the northern 215 beltway
you guessed it we're
centennial bowling
so maybe i should have said we're
ramping down part of the centennial gold
coast that's what's about to happen
again
starting sunday night nevada department
of transportation closing the ramp
from the north 95 to the east 215 until
five monday morning
this ramp has been closed many times for
a night or two as work continues on the
155 million dollar final phase of the
project grinding on
however this particular closure it is
actually scheduled to run
every night next week until friday
morning good way to get around it check
this out
uh get off the north 95 at ann road go
over to jones
then up the beltway that'll get you onto
the east 215. now
even if you do not consider yourself a
junior traffic buddy nerd
ndot's website about the entire
centennial area's got a ton of great
information about the huge project
we've got that link and links to this
and all of our centennial bold stories
on the website 8newsnow.com click
traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8
8 news now dot com